so it was a normal flight day we're
going out to reap unch currency for
landing at the ship in the evening there
was nothing crazy about it I took off
and as I was climbing away from the deck
I put my gear up realized I had a gear
malfunction so immediately pulled the
power back slowed the aircraft down so I
wouldn't over speed the landing gear and
then went just above the ship at about
2,000 feet and started talking to
paddles who is another jet pilot in the
tower that controls us when we land
they're also up there if we have a
problem
they have their book reader they help us
walk through the situation since we're
single piloted aircraft for a while I
flew by the ship
I did a pro chat 300 feet so he could
see my landing gear and give me an idea
of what was going on and determined that
my nose gear did not come back down at
this point it's time to figure out how
do I get the jet back on the deck safely
with only three landing gear so
eventually major Murphy came over the
radio and told me that the ship had this
amazing invention that was like
basically a stool that was built
specifically for this reason the ship
has a lighting system on what we call
spot 7 that we use to land at an exact
spot every time
so the difference with this landing was
that I was going to step it down 50 40
30 20 feet to make sure I was aligned
and stabilized before major Murphy would
clear me to land at 20 feet so that it's
had the best chance to actually put the
nose on the stool so I come in and at
this point I've kind of forgotten that I
don't have a nose gear I'm just focused
on landing that's what I decide to do so
I'm at 20 feet stabilized and I can't
see the stool I don't even know it's
there I didn't see it coming over the
end of the ship I look for it I remember
looking for it and thinking oh boy this
is going to get interesting so I never
saw the stool so I go to idle I remember
my main gear hitting and also in my nose
dropping and the drop more than I
expected but at that point I was along
for the ride
I don't remember I don't remember
feeling it bounce like it did on the
videotape
I remember feeling it just got hit and
that was it
but then I had to sit there from him a
minute and remember how to turn the shut
the jet off and everything it was pretty
big relief I didn't realize how much I
was shaking until I got out of the
aircraft
the most interesting part looking back
at the video and watching the video was
I didn't realize that nobody was on the
flight deck when I came over to land in
case something went wrong went bad
now that was neat having everyone come
out and congratulating me and stuff it
was a little overwhelming at first for a
moment I just wanted to catch my breath
we pride ourselves at landing on the
ship perfectly like this in the same
spot every time and doing the same thing
over and over again but there's no way
to train to land in this kind of
situation